well you can only imagine the nerves
coursing through that man's body having
not taken a big league mound in one day
shy of two years noah syndergaard
finally gets to do that tonight for the
first time since september of 2019 and
everybody in this ballpark is really
just tingling in anticipation there's
not a lot for this team to play for
right now but seeing noah cinder going
out on the mound
brings a lot of excitement to city field
right now
and he gets rojas with a high fastball
first batter in two years and cindergard
notches a strikeout four straight fast
balls and then one up the ladder there
[Applause]
and he gets him with a change up so
cinegar throwing three change-ups out of
four pitches in that attack he strikes
out chisholm
back-to-back strikeouts for noah
de la cruz cracks one on the ground down
to vr at third the throw has alonso
moving his feet he stays on the bag and
cindergard works a one two three inning
in his first outing in the big leagues
in nearly two years trevor rogers making
his 25th start this season coming off a
career-high 10 strikeouts against the
nationals
rogers wins that battle against bayez
gets the strikeout his first of the
night and sets the vets down in order
trevor williams comes out of the bullpen
for new york jesus sanchez lewin diaz
and louis brinson do up for the marlins
and jesus sanchez got all of that one
oh baby that thing traveled a mile and
it gives the marlins a one to nothing
lead
well he just ambushed a fastball what
power what extension what a swing a no
doubter to right over everything
man he did not miss that one absolutely
squared it up
one two coming and henry grounds one
down to first and alonso gets his big
body in front of it and makes the play
back here at city field we go to the
bottom of the third inning marlins with
a one-nothing lead and it's been six up
six sent down
by trevor rogers
and goes below the zone this time four
strikeout number four
now that time beats him
in on the hands a
fastball for a strikeout and that's five
for rogers
blows him away and he strikes out the
side six strikeouts
for trevor rogers and five in a row we
go to the fourth inning in the nightcap
of the doubleheader one nothing miami
de la cruz strikes out to start at the
top of the fourth that's four strikeouts
now for williamson relief
brenson center field a base hit
diaz moves up 90 feet marlins have two
on
one two coming
he finds that one into right field for a
base said diaz to third will be held up
there by trey hillman oh no
overran first base and now they got
tagged
alvarez just assumed that everybody was
going to keep on running
diaz got the stop sign at third properly
stopped and alvarez never stopped he
gets a base hit but he's tagged out
to end the inning
so that's 11 up and 11 down for rogers
and now baez
and he lines one base hit
so the mets have their first base runner
of this game
bae has a two out single after rogers
had retired the first 11.
and for javi baez now a 12-game hitting
streak
so now pete alonso will step in
and a ground ball to miggy it's short
he makes the play
well a hit surrendered by rogers but he
still has a one to nothing lead
the tying run in scoring position first
time the mets have had a runner as far
as second base in this game
and he hooks one in the left field for a
base hit the are around 30 is being
waved home brynson's got a strong arm
his throat is cut off
oh man tying one comes home one heck of
an at-bat by pilar
terrific at-bat
and
you gotta let this ball come home
and it was up it was offline
it could have been
yep
the timing of it just looked like there
was going to be a play at the plate
boy the arson run
pitcher's best friend double play
mcneal rips one but it's caught by
[Applause]
mcneil hit a bullet
and pilar has doubled off first base to
end the inning
that's toward the middle baez with a
sliding stop gets up the one hop throw
and alonso hung on for the out
wow
oh he just does something that makes
your eyes pop every game
ball that appeared to have no chance for
he not only got to it but he threw out a
speedy guy at first base
that's a fine play in a nice pick by
petey ross to pinch it in the first game
and drew a walk against stephen oaker
and he lines one at the left field for a
base hit
that's pinch hitting continues to be
stellar nemo waiting on a no one pitch
and again he squares pushes the butt
beautifully down to alvarez
who makes the throw on target
and now two are aboard for alonso
and this one is hit high
left side foul territory eddie alvarez
makes the catch near the tarp and
alonso pops out for the final out of the
inning
bender works around some trouble and we
head to the seventh
amazing season 66th game his last 16
cras went under two
and alvarez
is blown away with a high fastball
10th strikeout for mitt pitchers in this
game again the 1-2
and sierra golf's one of the air shallow
left and foul ground vr
reels it in to retire the side
may gets them on one two three let's
look for the walk-off at the bottom of
the seventh bender came around to get
the final out in the sixth he'll face
mccann vr and pilar in the home seventh
one and two
and a cold strike three outside corner
driven toward left center field back in
the gap and it goes to the wall
so vr who doubled to right center as a
right hand banner doubles to left center
as a left-hand batter and the mets have
the potential winning run in scoring
position with one out so now conforto
and will they pitch to him
nope they're to put them on they'll
pitch to mcneil instead
so that sets up the double play
possibility
[Applause]
ground ball jazz has it the flip to
rojas and over to first a double play so
for the second time in as many at bats
jeff mcneil
is doubled up jerry's familia will pitch
the eighth
inning
sierra oh he's got picked off and he
does get picked
sierra took a couple of phantom steps
towards second and famiglia
turned at that point
and nails him
a huge first out one two coming to rojas
hit on the ground alonso knocks it down
gets to his knees hits familia guffy out
beautifully done
one two coming
struck him out
quite an inning for familia his first
career pick off punctuates it with a
strikeout welcome back 1-1 the score as
we head to the last of the eighth inning
dylan floro is on the pitch
one and two
[Applause]
and floro gets the strikeout a big out
number one here in the eighth inning
two two coming
and nimo rolls one to the right side
diaz oh boy just in time i don't know if
he purposely did that or if it came off
his glove and just popped in the air
into his bare hand yeah i thought it
came up ran up his arm
mcneil at third lendore at second 1-2
pitch is a ground ball miggy's got it
down to a knee the throw to first is in
time and we play on to the ninth inning
brian de la cruz leads off at the top of
the ninth two-two coming
slider struck him out wow
so hand comes back from 2-0 to get dela
cruz for the first down
and diaz lifts one to left chasing
mcneil back
still going on the track makes the catch
but they're gonna have best pitch to
alonso with the winning run at second
base
toward the middle comes right off the
rubber
to chisholm who gets the out but it's a
productive out for alonso moves the wing
run to third with one out james mccann
trying to get by his home from third
with the winning run
and james triples went back to the
mountain bias trying to score it's
fumbled in the midst win it
bias running on contact on a ball back
to the mound
bass couldn't handle it cleanly and the
mitts sweep the doubleheader